-Our next guest is a very funny
comedian whose new book,
"A Bathroom Book for People
Not Pooping or Peeing
But Using the Bathroom
as an Escape,"
is available November 16th.
Season three of his show,
"Joe Pera Talks with You,"
premieres November 7th
on Adult Swim.
Let's take a look.
-At what point does it go
from sitting to laying down?
-45 degrees?
-That makes sense.
-I always say when you see
more ceiling than wall.
[ All laugh ]
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to
the show our friend Joe Pera.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back, Joe.
It's so lovely to see you.
-It's very nice to be here and
have the audience here again.
-Yeah.
It's so -- Very exciting.
-We're very excited
to have you, as always.
Your excitement, as always,
is palpable.
[ Laughter ]
In that clip -- I always love,
you know, reminding you of this,
that you're in that clip
with Gene Kelly...
-Right.
-...who was a cameraman
on this show.
-Mm-hmm.
-You came on this show.
You met him.
You basically hired him away
from his life as a cameraman
and he became an actor.
-I'm sorry.
[ Laughter ]
But -- Yeah.
He retired from this show
last year,
and then I asked him
to come do one more season
of the television program,
and he was just --
I think he just wanted to rest,
but he's such a nice guy
that he couldn't say no,
and I'm glad --
-And you did let himself rest
because that scene was about
picking out a La-Z-Boy for him.
So, really,
all his acting had to be
was sitting
in a comfortable chair.
-Yes, exactly. The episode's
about helping him
pick out a retirement chair.
I guess something that's --
he could sit and unpack
the last 72 years of his life
while watching daytime TV.
-Yeah. How was --
You obviously take a chair
very seriously
and its level of comfort.
And since we have you here
and you have a good eye for it,
how is the chair you're in now?
-It's, uh -
It's pretty nice, actually.
It's very exciting to think
of all the celebrities
who have sat here
over the years
like Elizabeth Taylor and such.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Now...
Joe, you have a very specific
title of this book,
"A Bathroom Book for People
Not Pooping or Peeing
But Using the Bathroom
as an Escape."
Was it important for you
to make sure they knew
exactly what kind of book
they were buying?
-The publishing company
said it's way too long,
but I don't know.
I see --
It's very nice when you
have to read it out loud on TV.
It makes me chuckle backstage.
[ Laughter ]
But I just love that things
that kind of are what they say,
and I wanted to make sure
everybody knows
what they're getting
as soon as they see the book.
-You have a few tips in here,
not just for how to spend
the time in the bathroom
but, you know, how to re-enter
the social event they were at.
Sort of like things you can say
to break the ice
post-trip to the bathroom.
Could you share a few of those?
-Sure.
-Yeah.
-Do you mind?
-Yeah, go for it.
-Thanks. Yeah.
Basically, I wanted
to make it easy for people
to rejoin the party
or whatever else they're doing.
So I wrote an epilogue
that's all kind of --
-This is the epilogue.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And some conversation starters
that you can use
on the other side of the door.
[ Laughter ]
Such as...
you can ask the person,
"Do you believe
in free will or fate?"
[ Laughter ]
"And then depending
on their answer,
you can drink their drink."
[ Laughter ]
"Do Kit-Kats count
as granola bars?"
[ Laughter ]
Could talk for hours about that.
-Sure.
Now, can I ask another question?
You've got the book done.
Another season of
"Joe Pera Talks to You."
When you have these works
behind you in your rear-view,
do you start focusing
on things, other projects
that you want to get done?
-Yeah.
I'm kind of in that nice period
right now where we're able to,
you know,
feel free of the ideas,
feel like we did a good-enough
job and can put them down,
and now I've been thinking
about new ones to pick up.
And I actually found this pitch.
This a real pitch
that I pitched to Adult Swim.
-Okay.
-At the same time
as the original
"Joe Pera Talks You to Sleep."
-Uh-huh.
-And they chose that one.
-But this is the other one?
-This is the other one
that could have been.
And I wanted to share it
with you in case,
I don't know, you're interested
in producing it.
-Okay.
Do you want me to read
about it a little bit?
-Sure.
-Or do you want me to --
It's called "My Two Cars."
[ Laughter ]
-It's a real pitch I wrote
with my buddy Dan Licata.
-Yeah, a very funny man.
-Uh-huh. And you want to read
the tag line at the top?
-Sure. "'My Two Cars.'
With great cars
comes great responsibility."
-Right.
-Okay.
-And then the summary is
"Imagine -- you're lucky enough
to own both a PT Cruiser
and a Mini Cooper.
[ Laughter ]
Your day-to-day life
would be insane."
[ Laughter ]
"Keith Ass [bleep]
does own both of these
exciting cars.
And while things
are really, really good,
there's one problem.
You can only drive
one car at a time."
[ Laughter ]
But no matter which car Keith
chooses, it's always a trip."
And then...
-Can you just read --
Can I read?
-Yeah, please.
-This is -- Episode three
would be the one
that would sell me.
-Yes.
-This is where I would
green-light it.
"Keith goes to
the premiere of a film
by P.T. Anderson
starring Bradley Cooper.
When he shows up
in his PT Cruiser,
P.T. Anderson loves it.
Unfortunately,
Bradley Cooper hates it.
So Keith takes the subway home
and drives back
in his Mini Cooper
to prove he has both."
That is...
[ Applause ]
...gold.
-Thank you.
Dan Licata asked me
to include one thing
that we left out --
that Keith Ass [bleep]
is also Supreme Court justice.
[ Laughter ]
So it's gives it a little depth
and, you know...
-Yeah. Sure. I felt like there
wasn't enough going on with
Keith Ass [bleep].
That's Joe Pera, everybody.
"A Bathroom Book for People
Not Pooping or Peeing
But Using the Bathroom
as an Escape"
is available November 16th.
And season three of
"Joe Pera Talks with You"
premieres November 7th
on Adult Swim.